here snoop's the new judge on uh super
gangster he's the new judge on
the voice is he really yep
isn't that don't think like that what
don't they like
help people guide people through well
they have there's like
there's like nick jonas what's up cat
there's like nick jonas
what's up there's nick jonas there's uh
uh blake shelton and uh there's a girl
oh and then kelly clarkson i know but
don't
christina aguilera was on that show yeah
yeah and then the dude from room five
was on there adam yeah so that's where
they pick they pick again they're like
team they work
with teams and they coach them and then
they compete
who's he who's gonna coach and say that
weird that is weird
make sure he's on the voice change
doesn't make sense at all but i'm pretty
sure he is
really that is weird who are we talking
about now
he's on the voice it's it's not it's not
american idol american idol is where the
real talents at
do you think that's where the real
telling is i know
who who's done anything it's about the
story
my dude with the guitar oh yeah yeah
yeah
the guy yeah he's not doing [ __ ] he's
doing weddings
what else you got how you know he
probably popping
he's not popping what's his name yeah
you you introduce this to us
like you can see that's mega mentor on
the voice he's a mega mentor mega mentor
what does that mean so that means he's
probably just giving him advice
advice on like how to deal with her
career oh ariana grande just signed on
the voice she's the judge for this
she's gonna she's been on there though
really ariana oh ariana grande yeah
ariana oh
i think you're sitting out glare oh yeah
she was uh he has john legend on there i
can't really
fan him you don't like zombies you don't
like chrissy teigen either right
i like chrissy oh really i like chris
john legend
not for you i don't get my real wait
where's that where's that guy at
with the guitar from the boys that was
good find him
i'm telling you you're barking up the
wrong tree because i introduced you to
him and i know the guy
and i know he's not popping how are you
gonna tell me
about a guy that i told you about and
then i say name one
and you mentioned him he won 10 years
ago but you said name one you probably
don't tic toc killing him he's probably
killing it
he said the voice blue look i don't
remember him i was blue
yeah i think you yeah i
[Applause]
i don't care what you say voicing
jermaine paul chris blue
yeah hey jordan smith probably did some
[ __ ] too yeah
chris blue is definitely at the uh yeah
when the fire and eisley bro
you can hire any of them for your
wedding yeah
any of them they will show up 500 easy
easy to reach out to five hundred
dollars
sundance head will show up to your
[ __ ] barbecue sundance head i said
season 11 so that means he oh these are
the winners these are the winners yeah
sundance sundance name
no one no one does [ __ ] that's why they
always make fun of the voice
like american idol's for stars the voice
is like whatever well you know
i feel like the x factor they do more
those people do more i like that like
right am i am i right good call so the x
factor
was created and that's how american
island came about it's the same creator
oh same people same same thing okay
and you know actually x factor not
everyone's singing everyone's like
it's just talent show oh no america i
was thinking america's got talent people
people pop off that's kind of the x
factor though yeah it seems like the
same world
x factor is not just singing right yeah
they're like juggling [ __ ] there's
magicians
no i think x factor x factor is english
english yeah but you're saying america
got talent right yeah america's got
talent
i mean you might get a shot in vegas or
some [ __ ] again american idol building
straight
stars doug brooke people have sold
i mean comedians that have done america
america's got talent
selling out tours he's basically going
to see creatures
and yeah and you're saying preacher got
big off america against town
did he win it uh lost to a girl who
played with dogs yeah
and he's been able he's been able to
really springboard off that he makes
sense
yeah what other comics uh sam uh sam uh
i don't know
uh tourette's uh he's got tourette's
[ __ ]
andrew lynch drew lynch yeah he's
another one
those guys have been been able to bank
off oh yeah and um jackie fabulous
mm-hmm
you [ __ ] i'm talking i'm
talking
harry underwood selling out arenas you
talk about drew lynch selling out the
miami improv i'm talking big boy
[ __ ] here man but singing in comedy we
can't compare that yeah let's let's go
to single let's stick to singers let's
go okay so
so far because any comedian not every
comedian is an arena comedian
yeah like a lot of i mean it's tough to
be coming up here's my problem when you
say popping off
i think our definition of popping off is
different
okay you're talking i'm talking big [ __ ]
man i'm not talking about
selling out an improv i'm talking like
millions and millions and millions of
dollars in fans opposed to selling out a
weekend in houston
damn well i mean he's lit
shut up just it depends what popping off
me okay
i i mean if you're headlining the venice
underground it means you made it then
yeah you pop it doug
no i'm not saying venus underground
these people have
actually like have good tours you know
but i'm but it's comedian
i i see what you're saying i see what
you're saying but
he was right i'm sorry i'm not saying
he's wrong no no he what did he do
like he gave them like but preacher was
popping before that
no i'm sure he was doing decent he was
doing
he had stand up like preacher's a beast
six years ago
yeah he was only six years in yeah but
but he wasn't doing bad
no he wasn't doing he i mean yeah he was
it was it was a lot it was a leaping pad
it was it for sure helped okay that's
what we said but he's basically saying
i'm talking carry on dude i'm talking
[ __ ] you money
i'm talking carrie underwood she got
[ __ ] you money yeah absolutely
carrie underwood yeah okay what yeah
that guy juggling you're telling me no
that nope
nope it's a launching board i guess yeah
but american i was just different it's
on 20 seasons
like usually but you fall in love with
those people you have to like it's like
what two months is a two months
but who's who's the last person from
america and i know that really pop thank
you that's a great question uh
two seasons ago alejandro he sells out
like you know how you're saying sell
out he like he's he has a huge following
is he got runner up
no what kind of musician would you say
he is jen um
just like with pop i wouldn't say he's
so talented it's like
that's a good question like i said r b
pop he's like he's like an indie r
b pop like like he kind of has his own
lane when it comes
to super creative brandon talks about
him a lot so
i don't talk about that much i probably
reference a year because i could educate
these [ __ ]
i'm not hurting that's fair every time
you talk about american idol you talk
about him and it's usually about
but when people say they don't know who
he is like yeah he's he's super talented
it's a question
it goes what happened to american idol
alejandro so he's is he still doing
great
i'll go to his instagram i mean before
the pandemic
every tour he had is sold out so again
it depends what you mean popping me yeah
okay now is he kevin hart i don't know
633
oh i remember this guy i don't remember
him i remember this guy
he he like amazing so he's just like a
tour now
we stupid town we actually watched the
clip of him on here
chin's like yeah i told you i think he's
like the best one of the best we've ever
heard
wow you should see the talent on this we
watched his uh
audition video on here yeah he plays
everything yeah
guitar singing yeah i think what's tough
is
uh american idol's yeah american idol is
kind of like the ultimate fighter like
you're into this weird contract
oh yeah that's right so like carrie
underwood didn't like start making [ __ ]
you until she got out of that deal
notice how she doesn't [ __ ] with
american hell
at all but she doesn't come back for
[ __ ]
most people who win don't i didn't
realize that there was a contract
on great [ __ ] carry
i carry underwear and shit's like that's
how you get your start girl jordan
jordan sparks spoke about that as well
she was like i hate it the worst
contract i had was american idol
damn and she didn't she didn't even win
but then would she be discovered if you
weren't on there like that was it used
to be such a big platform but she didn't
win though so i'm trying to stay like
but
because because if you get in the top 10
then you go on a tour the top 10 go on a
tour together
so there's all the other things in the
top 10 they go on their own tour
together
because obviously there's millions and
millions of people watch so they're
selling out
how long are they in this country it's
years and they own a lot of your [ __ ]
so carrie's still under it no she's out
oh she was like season
three or something oh good okay first
ones yeah like kelly clarkson was like
she was like three or four clarkson was
one two might have been carrie underwood
i don't know oh i didn't know i didn't
know her she was that long ago
yeah it's been a hot minute when the
fantasia win
did fantasia win yes she won so that but
i mean
it sounds like this contract can like
[ __ ] you yeah it's tough though right
because the american i was like well no
one know who you are if it wasn't for us
yeah that's true that's fair that's fair
but still though that's a master it's
tough right yeah are you doing they said
ultimate fighters kind of saying oh yeah
they had me i was fighting gonzaga like
top
10 guy gonzaga cro cop nogara for like
base level money yeah but then they're
like well the reason you get these big
fights people know who you are because
of the
fighter yeah so that's so like if i was
a manager i wouldn't have a kid going
ultimate fighter now
no it's not big anymore so you just get
that shitty contract you're in it for
for a long time oh they don't have
ultimate fighter anymore or are they
it's coming it's just coming back oh
it's just brian ortega uh
the coaches oh hell it's only on espn
plus oh
we gotta have espn it's a little tough
what was it on when you did it
oh biggest season of all time be cool be
cool
i remember that biggest season of all
time wow
it came on right before england let them
know brandon let him know
i don't know it came on why didn't
[ __ ] what came on right before
inkmaster came on so maybe like people
just like like stayed
they said they're like oh [ __ ] hey
you just gonna wear that hat like that
just gonna come in
looking like school boy poo
[Laughter]
i thought i was looking like hello not
cool
would you just gonna come here i thought
everything's over
[Laughter]
i was talking [ __ ] about shows i don't
even [ __ ] watch yeah man i don't know
what i'm rambling this is my [ __ ]
i know it's like if i want to win i'll
give you that
but you're right like like preacher and
some guy it depends
it depends yeah i guess i'm thinking
because yeah i'm thinking of superstars
yeah yeah
you're right i'm thinking like
superstars and the voice has never had a
suit
like yeah even american idol talk [ __ ]
about like if you want to become a star
you come here you kind of like that's
them throwing jabs and people
if no one's ever done [ __ ] from the
voice also people probably know
more american idol people even if they
didn't win then they wouldn't know the
voice
if you really think about it do you
think that boys have auditions like the
prizes
like american nightmare 100 a lot of
them notifications won't do that
audition stuff
but they do say american isle is harder
to make okay because there's so many
people dude
i'm telling you and i'm not just saying
the talent level american house season
is nutsos
i don't know who the [ __ ] gentlemen
there's one black guy who's kind of the
favorite this
huge every how long we're pretending to
have diabetes he's so out of shape oh
but he's such a good singer
rubenstein
he sings rihanna shine bright like a
diamond and they
dude i was singing rihanna really bro i
love rihanna
i love her too dude she's so [ __ ]
talented
they said really just just just type in
american idol
sing bright like a bright like a diamond
2021. they say rihanna seemed like she
got bronchitis is that true
no i don't i don't know what barbecue
rat that said that
are you happy about that and you also
look the same when you took a picture of
mike tyson francine
[Laughter]
he's such a heavily favor to win i think
it's gonna [ __ ] up the viewership
you know when like someone's so good
like oh he's gonna win
yeah get ready
[Applause]
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ] that give me two
every performance is like this by the
way everyone's a home run every single
one's a grand slam you're like
do they not have those like awkward
funny ones anymore where like
they stop doing those they don't you
know where you might they make fun of
can they yeah
that's done oh so it's all like legit
all super talented people like that
i like the real shitty ones but i'm a
mean person
so okay but everything every time it
performs like a home run so you're like
all right and then they bring out people
after me like all right [ __ ] there's
only one girl who has
the most ridiculous ash version in your
life i sent to the justin like dog
holler at this chick
she was built for justin oh they took it
she was like a skinny waist yeah
ass is like yeah who was
uh who was the asian dude that popped
off this
but he wasn't good yeah i know who
you're talking about it's william
william
they don't do that anymore damn now it's
all like super sad stories
oh really because that's the people
because they people
because i think people just like to
watch you know
i like talent talent climb i guess the
talent's nuts like there's a homeless
mom on there and she's pretty good
yeah it's nuts [ __ ] it's crazy
yeah don't start you don't did they make
you cry
i've cried before yeah he came over here
and said i cried last night oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah yeah they do it on
purpose i'm like god damn man
and then you want them to win is that
the homeless
her and her mom were homeless yeah they
lived out of the car she used the super
homeless one
all right and her dad was homeless too
jeez bro
i'm not about to yeah oh it's too much
yeah i like and when they tell a story
i'm like please be [ __ ] good please
be good
and then
and then what one uh girl she's like i'm
gonna sing an original i could tell
her confidence is not there she gets on
the piano and katy perry is like hold on
what do you mean because usually when
you sing original it's a bad idea okay
he's like why he said well like
how did this song come about before you
sing this should i go well my mom walked
out on us
uh like four weeks ago so it's a song i
wrote about her
like this this to my mom and she starts
playing oh it's so good
but she wasn't that talented oh don't
get me wrong she was
good but that not that good you know
but they but they pass her anyways yeah
like oh it's hard to judge that though
like you you know it's not though
because talent followed her
like this the white girl with the
ridiculous ass came on next and she can
sing like that black guy oh yeah
oh they're almost the same they're all
the same person yeah it's why do you
think that guy do you like that guy
what do you think i didn't think it was
amazing but i thought it was good
wow i'm serious well god damn it
it's not korean he said he's the
favorite
what the no no definitely really good
but i wasn't like he's not
okay he's not my favorite there's a kid
on there reminds me a little bit of like
ben harper
and he only does acoustic yeah he's
[ __ ] hard
what's that like i don't know what's his
name what's his name ben harper no no
the guy oh i i don't know i don't know
names
ben harper plays the guitar like super
crazy right yeah
big contestant he has a hat on um
he's a like a head like that he's from
utah he's a guitarist too right not a
hat like that
not a helmet a white guy
um oh that kid was great i'm the blind
kid
the who a blind so if you got american
top
you scroll down chin if you go to
american idol top 24. we'll move on from
rick and i after this because on that
yeah
because people don't watch america like
jesus christ dude i don't even watch it
yeah but i'm intrigued though i know not
her
not uh nope not her there's a lot of
young kids on there it's a lot of girls
like some 15 year olds
this one no no he's really good though
and i was like
she's really good
whoa nope is that kid in play nope
he's good though nope nope
nope nope there's no
no 100 hundred's really good no hold on
the heels killing it keep going he'll
have a hat on that bet keep going
yes there he is all right wyatt pike
super talented
uh country you're gonna dig him chin no
white like folk
oh folks
[Music]
he's also ready for it like he's been
performing gigs on his own all around
the country
like driving so he like has the
experience
so he's a beast on stage too like the
moment's not too big for him and he
writes all his own [ __ ] too
this one he didn't write but michael
stayed at the left factory
right away you go bro i figured out what
you look like i'm like what this wrote a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son